we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
caller who is not happy with me
take a listen David this is Robert in
Riverside
dude you are driving me insane with
calling her
tulsi gabbard orga bard or whatever you
come up with her name is Tulsi Gabbard I
know Tulsi is probably because she the
Russian tool Jesus dude please stop yeah
just remember English is my second
language and I do the back way we know
when I try to say amy klobuchar
I sometimes make a mistake when I ca say
tulsi gabbard it could be wrong I'm
doing the best I can here we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today
remember those Bridgegate convictions
for that completely outrageous george
washington bridge scandal several years
ago the Supreme Court might toss out the
Bridgegate convictions we'll tell you
why on the bonus show Donald Trump is
slamming Apple for refusing to unlock
the iPhones of suspected criminals and
we're going to talk about that and
encryption and data security and so many
other things including due process and
we will talk about Donald one of Donald
Trump's former national security
advisors not the most recent one but one
of the earlier ones Michael Flynn the
indicted Michael Flynn Michael Flynn now
wants to withdraw his guilty plea
altogether we will tell you why and we
will tell you what the likely
repercussions of that are how where is
that happening where how do you get
access to that that's the bonus show the
bonus show happens every day it's in
addition to the broadcast show it's an
extra show we do every day
Pat joins me for the show Monday through
Thursday Friday Pat hosts the bonus show
subscribe at join pakman.com to get
instant access become a patron at
atleast the $5 a month level at
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
get instant access all good ways to get
access to the world's famous bonus show
where things continue otherwise we will
see you on tomorrow's